our drug policy has really been
traditionally based on racism and
moralizing the reason that the currently
illegal drugs are illegal has nothing to
do with a scientific evaluation of the
relative risks and benefits otherwise
you could never come up with a situation
where marijuana is illegal and tobacco
is legal you cannot make a rational
argument for that that comes from racism
and the and colonialism the drug laws
were made in explicitly racist
circumstances for explicitly racist
reasons for example the first anti
cocaine laws were made because cocaine
supposedly made black men impervious to
bullets and prone to getting involved
with white women this is complete
nonsense where there is no science to it
whatsoever and yet it was published in
the New York Times in the early 1900s so
this is where our laws come from and we
have to be honest about that and we have
to stop pretending that there is some
kind of rational basis for the laws that
we currently have then what we need to
do is realize that you can't make policy
based on I think it's bad for you to
have unearned pleasure you have to make
policy based on does this hurt you does
this hurt other people and the that's
where harm reduction comes from the
basic idea of harm reduction is what
policy will most reduce the harm related
to drugs and once you start to focus on
harm you have to look not only at harm
associated with drugs but harm
associated with drug policy and this is
why so many harm reduction people
rapidly become legalized errs because
the harm associated with drug
prohibition has not produced the results
that people would like it does not stop
addiction it does not you know prevent
kids from using drugs it makes the kids
who use drugs be at higher risk of dying
from them it doesn't you know save
society's productivity you violate
keeping people from taking substances
that will make them not work on it just
doesn't work and when you think about it
if addiction is defined as compulsive
behavior despite negative consequences
and you're trying to use negative
consequences in order to stop it
something is seriously wrong there so
our drug policy has to acknowledge the
reality that punishment doesn't fix
addiction and that putting drug users in
cages does nothing but worsen the
problem and it doesn't deter kids this
idea that like oh if we just really
stigmatize this and make everybody hate
drug users then kids will never use
drugs kids are gonna do stupid risky
things you want to reduce the chances
that those things will kill them the
idea that we can prevent adolescence
from having sex or prevent adolescents
from doing some kind of risky behavior
it's just absurd this you know comes out
before humans even evolved again this is
where it comes back to racism our image
of the typical drug user or the typical
drug addict is basically the same as our
racist stereotype of whichever groups we
happen to be targeting so criminal lying
manipulative deceitful on you know all
of these things that we project onto
other people and then stigmatize and
attack them for um we do the same with
drug users obviously if you make a
behavior that someone feels is essential
to their survival illegal they are going
to lie to protect that behavior that
doesn't mean that they're fundamentally
a dishonest person the reason that we
continue to have these stereotypes about
who drug users are is because of the
ongoing racism of our society and until
we acknowledge that like I am the
typical drug user if there is such a
thing on you know I don't look like your
stereotype but that doesn't mean that
the stereotype is accurate um so I think
that's a really important thing that
people really have to learn because for
too long the media has enabled the
racist view of addiction and has enabled
people to
sorters say oh I'm not the typical
addict like you know and I used to say
that and then I realized wow that's like
kind of racist you know um and you know
it comes from images that we shouldn't
have ever had so I think that the way to
you know get beyond that and the way to
help people with addiction is to
understand that people with addiction
are not seeking extra pleasure they are
not hedonist who are just out there
having so much fun using that you can't
stop them unless you put them in jail
people who get addicted which are only
10 to 20 percent of the people who use
drugs like cocaine and heroin and
prescription opioids those people have
problems the drugs seem like a solution
to them until we recognize that those
people are seeking reasonably rationally
to deal with emotional and psychological
problems and sometimes economic problems
we are not going to solve this problem
and one of the things that I think we're
actually in denial about with regard to
the opioid epidemic is that while big
pharma certainly didn't do anything good
here what they to say that this is
caused by Purdue Pharma selling
oxycontin is to miss the fact that the
people who are overwhelmingly becoming
addicted are people who are either
falling out of the middle class or never
managed to get into it if you actually
look at the economics of this problem
it's not that middle class people
certainly don't get addicted and it's
not that rich people don't get addicted
it's just that if your life is despair
and you feel like it will never get any
better which is often the case when you
lose the American dream where you lose
the hope for your future opioids are
going to become very attractive and the
idea that we can solve this by taking
away the supply is just ridiculous I
mean as soon as we started cracking down
on the pill mills we started seeing a
rise in heroin use this is not an
unpredictable outcome since we
supposedly believe that addiction is a
disease why would we think that simply
cutting off the supply from some patient
like turning over like making a thousand
people we take this doctor out there's a
thousand people and was draw now we
don't provide any help for them on why
are we thinking this is going to fix
this problem and why are we thinking
that an illicit market is not going to
immediately grow up to satisfy that
demand on the people who you know the
other thing that's important
economically is that in this is that
drug dealing is a way to make a living
and if you have desperate unhappy people
without jobs some of whom want to
self-medicate and some of whom would
just like to actually get some money
you're going to have a drug selling
problem and you are not going to solve
that problem by putting people in jail